Irish English has some grammatical
features that don't exist in standard
English there's a plural form of you use
I meet you outside the cinema I heard
you are planning a trip in Dublin you
might also hear a plural possessive
adjective yeser instead of your give me
his are plates so I can put them in the
dishwasher instead of saying someone has
done something Irish people might say
they are after doing something I'm only
after finishing work meaning I've just
finished work
we're after getting home from Cork
meaning we've gotten home from Cork this
is one feature of Irish English which I
really found confusing the first time I
heard it